il ya le breakbeat aussi qui dans
l'actualité jean-marc fauves qui avait
été correspondant en grande bretagne bré
exit qui finalement le chef barnier qui
dirige les négociations a dit qu' on en
avait pas fini avec la première phase et
que pédaler dans la semoule
mais c'est pas vraiment surprenant parce
que tout le monde est embêté aussi c'est
une patate chaude et par dessus le
marché on a un pouvoir politique
britannique qui lui aussi est embêté je
pense que ça joue beaucoup
c'est à dire que dire madame mail n'est
pas dans une situation politique très
confortable les contesté au sein de son
parti il ya le congrès de solliciter des
conservateurs britanniques cette semaine
elle est contestée partie par boris
johnson ils sont pas unanimes en fait
ils sont parents rangs serrés derrière
elle donc je pense qu'elle a un appui
politique faible qui fait que ça ça ça
altère ses prises de position ça retarde
les négociations et ça pourrait durer un
moment